[تصفيق]
حكومه يمنيه في طور تشكل في اسرائيل
بنيامين نتنياهو يوقع اتفاقا ائتلافيا مع
حزب اليمين المتشدد عوتس ما يهوديت زعيم
الحزب اثمار المثير للجدل الاعرب عن الرضا
انا سعيد لانني الاتفاق على الوزارات التي
سيحصل عليها عدس ما يهودي سيتيح لنا
تحقيقه وعودنا الانتخابيه من اجل تعزيز
امن النقب والجليل والارياف بموجب الاتفاق
سيصبح اليمني المتشدد وزيرا للامن القومي
الوزيرا للامن الداخلي بصلاحيات موسعه
ووزيرا للتراث يعنى بالاثار حتى الواقعه
ضمن الضفه الغربيه المحتله فضلنا الاشراكه
في مجلس الوزراء الامنيه
اثمار من غير محامي مستوطن في الضفه
الغربيه ودينا في 2007 بالتحريض العنصري
ضد العرب وبدعم الارهاب فضلا عن مواقفه
المناهضه للمثليه الجنسيه
وصعوبات لتوافق مع شخصيه اخرى من
الصهيونيه الدينيه فقد وصلت المفاوضات مع
بيبسي الى طريق مسدود والاسيه ما بعد ان
تراجع رئيس الوزراء المكلف عن منحه وزاره
الدفاع وذلك بسبب الضغوط الامريكيه
الائتلاف المرتقب بين اليمين واليمين
المتطرف بدعامه بنيامين نتنياه فرض نفسه
بعد الانتخابات التي جرت مطلع الشهر
الجاري ويؤمل ان ينهي اربع سنوات من عدم
الاستقرار السياسي
وستكون الحكومه المقبله الاكثر يمينيه في
تاريخ اسرائيل الامر الذي سيضع نتنياه تحت
الضغط
[تصفيق]